jean baptiste euros 100 bonjour bonjour
madame cupidité ravi de vous saluer de
saluer les auditeurs et les auditrices
de martinique la première alors vous
êtes candidat aux élections législatives
vous vous présentez dans la liste dans
la circonscription du nord sur la liste
alliance matinik alors pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin écoutez un
véritable constat la circulent la
circonscription nord est assez vaste et
vanessa de maria schell cher
d'abord un double objectif représentait
cette circonscription toute cette
circonscription est donc c'est pour cela
que moi qui suis de sainte marie
j'ai choisi ma suppléante achète cher
parce que la côte caraïbe du prêcheur
jus ce qu'achète cher n'oubliant pas
naturellement le monde vers fond saint
denis et le monde rouge qui vivent du
côté plutôt du côté code karim en
n'oubliant pas cette partie du
territoire et il est absolument
indispensable pour moi que le député sa
suppléante soit pleinement inscrit dans
son territoire alors quelles seront vos
deux ou trois projets prioritaires pour
la martinique si que vous comptez
défendre si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée
nationale alors un projet global d'abord
vous le savez j'étais en poste
quasiment tous les niveaux de
responsabilité et de décision de l'état
de cadre à deux préfectures au début de
ma carrière j'étais sous préfet ensuite
j'ai été conseiller puis chef de cannes
ministre il ya clairement un
déséquilibre dans notre relation de
terry 3 avec l'état donc naturellement
faire inverser les choses et puis toi
clairement un certain nombre de sujets
de grands sujets à dire que l'accès à la
santé chose extrêmement difficile la
brutalité de la vie point ces temps de
deux de nos concitoyens voyez qu'on va
de crise en crise et ce projet
extraordinaire que j'ai c'est à dire que
l'information de nos jeunes de manière à
ce qu'il en aille silsilah s'ils veulent
pour nos fonctions métiers restent sur
le territoire et la côte caraïbe à
laquelle je suis tant attaché autant
qu'à la côte carrie d'autant qu'à la
côte nord atlantique c'est un formidable
territoire la formation achète cher
universités cfa
le lycée hôtelier de bellefontaine et
tous ces établissements là donc nous
devons solidifier ses deux séries ces
deux t3 les mettre en synergie et avec
ma suppléante nous sommes pleinement
préparée nous n'avons jamais été tête de
liste n élections ce qui veut dire que
nous n'augmenterons aucun mandat de
responsables de premier plan pour aller
à cette élection alors on a parlé de
l'ensemble du territoire s'il faut
parler plus précisément de la
circonscription du nord quel serait
d'après vous les deux ou trois projets
ultra prioritaire qu'il faudrait
vraiment sur lesquels il faudrait
prendre plancher j'ai parlé de la santé
j'ai parlé de l'emploi on a un clerc
sujet d'insécurité qui ce qui se
développe en un clé un sujet de
préservation de ce beau territoire qui
le nord un sujet de renaissance de la
ville de la ville de saint pierre la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
et la montée des eaux aux prêcheurs on a
sept nombre d'autres d'autres sujets
sais bien que mon nevers fond saint
denis ses habitants qu'ils se
déplaçaient temps où la moine la moindre
formalité et puis naturellement ya ce
phénomène l'immigration illégale qui je
le rappelle est une et une souffrance
pour notre territoire parce que ce sont
des gens que des passeurs contre argent
laisse sur nos côtes en leur disant
débrouillez vous et nous maires sont à
la peine là dessus nos habitants sont
anna sont à la peine certes nous avons
une capacité d'accueil mais les choses
doivent être régulés et donc très
clairement il ya le sujet 2 l'appui de
l'état pour une meilleure surveillance
de nos mères et puis naturellement ça
c'est l'autre versant c'est cette lan
déconne qui a impact profondément nos
sols profondément d'autres notre mère
notre mère que ce soit du côté
atlantique ou du côté caribou qui
impacte notre vie quotidienne au point
que même les personnes qui ne sont pas
contaminés ont la crainte de l'être et
je crois qu'il faut absolument qu'on
soit actif qu'on soit dynamique là
dessus et puis je crois très clairement
que la martinique a besoin de visages
nouveaux
la martinique a besoin d'eau de lier à
nouveau lien de confiance
et ma suppléante hélène large n est
vraiment une femme de terrain et nous
allons pour cela
alors qu'avez vous à dire aux électeurs
pour terminer jean baptiste euros 106
vous devez vous adresser à eux mêmes en
s'aimant seconde martinique moi mais
tout mone lancé - sainte-marie mans
c'est papa - c'était mon épisode 1 et je
suis très attaché à cela c'est à dire
comment gady martinique sembel pays ni
des hommes des femmes extraordinaires
nous avons une belle personnalité c'est
tout ça vous nous voyez souvent parce
que la martinique ce n'est pas qu'un
territoire ce sont aussi des hommes des
femmes de belle vaillance donc faut que
nous fait toutes ces bêtes à goumain
parce que la martinique ces pays nous
c'est pas le bout du monde sans belle
pays
merci à vous jean baptiste euros de
seine merci infiniment et mes
remerciements vont aux auditrices et
auditeurs
[Musique]